[Musique]
conduite selon as
salut
ce projet semaine
le ghana
mais comme ça
je ne me sens
m
good d'i4i gens debout qui se regarde
c'est pas vrai
mais que les gens qui t'aiment pas
qu'ils seront bien
l'hôpital c'était pas pareil j'étais
moche dehors dedans ça correspondait
klaba plus efficace et plus on t'aime
alors eh bah ça n'a pas dû être facile
pour téteux
et que tu fais là
tu peux pas comprendre je suis désolé
la vie c'est de vaste blague car s'il te
plaît le loup
je ne prends que ce qui est à nous et tu
arrêtes de te faire chier avec le reste
jeudi
c'est comment profiter de la vie si on
savait ses vieilles méthodes
on sera tous entendent en profiter
prenez tout ce qui vient sans juger
may et surtout aucun regret
surtout savait tout sur tout